[Music]
it's immortal comma didn't work which I
would destroy you in oh yeah if the
league didn't work which I will destroy
you and destroy you already destroyed
you leave any tattoo didn't work wish I
would destroy you in so we're gonna do
the game that will finally settle the
score with rock-paper-scissors
Rochambeau we do rock-paper-scissors and
then we click alright okay
rock-paper-scissors
it's I'm waiting oh oh oh
they'll chose my friend Viktor the
person an epic draw in the smoke clear
is two rocks
I'm waiting it says server time out on
your side as information are they
sending oh my god I still like the name
you can that for me that was a really
nice name I know you're welcome it's
well deserved
[ __ ] face one should I create one since
I you should create one yeah you should
create one you can name me now no is
that okay
did Ken I'm sorry I'm sorry
there it is alright we're doing this
[ __ ] rock paper scissor baby what's
going down ready I'm ready
rock paper scissors choice today I would
yeah again yes I'm the rock paper
scissors not [ __ ] all tied by a paper
paper rock paper scissors [ __ ] you and
your paper
are you ready doubled up on paper you
think I can't develop a paper Sisson
what will happen the third time ha ha
you thought I would change scrub pay for
loose rock beautiful paper scissor ha
I gotta get ready scrub Phoenix
I said quiet buddy he's still playing
though it's okay uh come on Felix you
can do it just keep Todd now God beat me
oh you did it yeah that's right
you did it oh my gosh you're rock
totally crushed my scissors
yeah no I'm done that's it all right
who's the winner that's great oh my god
uh you got you got one on me I guess
that's that's ripping that doesn't win
in anyone's believe me Alicia once that
was so sick Oh Mike you're MLG Pro oh my
gosh I think I'm gonna go pro one day
guys hon oh my god that was intense
whoo gratulations mmm Phil feels good it
feels good to feel what are you gonna do
with your career now that you've you
know I think I'll go into pro and
rock-paper-scissor n't ezo keep playing
I mean a beating and I mean beating
cinnamon toast skin at
rock-paper-scissors like the holiday tea
with a sort of my fans I can do it
really anything
[Music]